[Music]
okay so this news anchor
I'll re I gotta read this story first
and then I'll then I'll play the video
uh Albany TV anchor Heather kovar
suspended after slurring through
broadcast did you see this do you see
this one Kevin I did see this and this
was uh this is fun well sure there's a
little clip up on Twitter however did
you get the
please tell me you got an extended one
Frozen nation has the entire news
broadcast and said it to me this is the
entire Bruce broadcast with her
beginning to hit
and let me tell you I've skimmed I
haven't you know I've skimmed she's
drunk through the whole thing
here you go she was suspended because
she was 31. drunk on here is this like
an unlisted
[Music]
no it's full it's a hundred seven
thousand I was gonna say because yeah I
want I want to [ __ ] find this later
because I might I might kill it about
half hour tonight on this
6 News starts now
developing now okay all right look okay
right away right
I mean whoa
right off the Jump Right
we're not in a good situation
look at her hair
I mean
that's that is
a whole [ __ ] day and evening of
drinking yeah yeah
I have a massive explosion and large
fire at a one oak plant in Medford
Oklahoma it is the Oklahoma it's the
location of a natural oh oh oh oh I love
this oh I'm so embarrassed I'm so
embarrassed for her
gas terminal that moves natural gas
through Kansas and Texas you see massive
underground stores of gas are at
risks
oh my God
and look I'll tell you this right now
and Royce will back this up
Nobody Drinks more than media people
right true particularly Fox News people
at least at least 10 15 years ago right
the fox and these people were known in
New York as like
the go-hards yeah the ones that would
actually go to a bar and hang out
together and but like
they almost all drink but they all know
how to time their drinking to go to work
yeah to be like all right I'm a little
toasty but let's go come on let's talk
about let's go to [ __ ] you know Joe
whatever with the weather and you're
like oh sh but this woman obviously got
started early and God went hard okay I
love this
patients have been ordered for the town
of Medford Oklahoma with uh unknown
fatalities injuries at the at this
injuries are unknown with the situation
all right well I I this is probably this
is the best thing I've seen in a long
time
well good afternoon like I was telling
you this morning
this morning starting at 6 a.m 7 A.M I
told you you know what today what a
beautiful day outside it is just amazing
and so a great time for a great time the
story is you couldn't pretend to be this
drunk stories her father died
and apparently she drank a lot because
of it my father died but that was just
telling you the reason and um that's the
reason she got so drunk Outdoors
off are they gonna fire is the
suspension just gonna be because I feel
like well okay so under those
circumstances cannot be reached by the
postal station said she was suspended
pending further investigation kovar said
on Twitter on Saturday that she would be
back on the air Sunday morning but she
did not appear on the station's
broadcast
CBS this also referenced the whatever
Sinclair broadcasting this doesn't
matter yeah I feel like I feel like you
should be able to go like look man just
go to take like a two-week rehab and
come back and don't ever do that [ __ ]
again
music the power spark console somebody's
saying she resigned this afternoon it's
a celebration of the 250th anniversary
of the village of Lansingburgh
man maybe maybe she sobers up if I go a
little bit more to the middle what do
you think this is so genuine
because like the greatest actress in the
world couldn't act this drunk that
there's certain
slurring and the things that I'm telling
you like dude the chick that plays D
Reynolds
couldn't do this good of a job
I skipped a little bit maybe she sobers
up yeah and toy vendors that supported
the annual Comic Con also people from
all over the Northeast her hair is worse
her hair is worse and Beyond have fought
to uh downtown Schenectady
the um Van Gogh exhibit since uh
[Music]
I think they let her keep going through
breaks they let her kept they let her
they probably it's a small Market who
else is around that's right there's only
one anchor he's a complete one acre look
at her dress do you think they have like
a hair and makeup department where they
could just dress up a [ __ ] young go
hard and well they don't think because
anyone doing her hair would have smelled
the booze on her but that's what I mean
she just came in nobody
fixed or I say hey you know let's fix
you up at least don't say the attraction
does it not look like she's wearing a
cocktail dress she wore the night before
too
has brought tens of thousands to the
area just a month ago all right so our
local CVS sixes and M
s scissors
oh Quint she's so amazing and she spoke
with local businesses and she and as
well as Discovery skills she's trying
harder to read the teleprompter because
she kind of like leans forward and opens
her eyes
it's almost as bad as Joe Biden
I just it's just I mean you [ __ ] up
but it's just it's still slow did she
resign is that the update today
over 15 000 people made their way to the
van Gogh exhibit skip ahead here because
it's happening in the area and across
the you know the area uh in the Navy
area bro
she's even bailing on it at this point
look at that face
there you go dude
you know
getting drunk is fun
but but man when you get too drunk yeah
it's it's just the faces you make the
way you talk the way it's It's the
funniest [ __ ] in the world really is
funny
okay a 4
isn't funny somebody being drunk and
trying to act not trunk well yeah is
[ __ ] hilarious every time yeah like
being a news anchor or like videos of
like when people are trying to explain
to the cops yeah just how sober they
actually are exactly you're not doing a
good job of this
uh let me tell you about this afford to
drive to the station
that's a good point I didn't even think
about that she probably did Paul is
actually dead another man is clinging to
life after shooting in Ohio officers say
that they responded to a call of shots
fired around 9 15 Friday night it comes
amid a week of protests in that City
he's still trying to do the news anchor
voice do you know you know what how much
money I would give to hear the producers
because there's probably two people in
the booth right now it's a small stage
probably two people right running all
the [ __ ] just to hear looking at each
other going like what do we do what do
we do here we're getting so much trouble
if we don't at least do them yeah we got
to do this we can't not do the news
Akron has implemented several cure fees
since the release of police body camera
footage showing the Fatal police
shooting of 25 year old Jalen Walker and
you see this video we have right here
now an Ohio Pastor calling for calm from
police and protesters
we all are in a heightened system okay
I'm in a uh maybe after oh oh the
meteorologist part's great okay okay so
we're gonna this is this is like yeah
we're gonna go here and then we're gonna
go to see his reaction okay here we go
and we are just lucky this weekend right
here is so amazing
meteorologist Craig Adams is right here
with here I'm sorry Craig Adams why did
I say that of course clearly like you're
taking a live look over uh downtown oh
God oh God oh God is he there's no way
this I don't care how good this
weatherman is there's no way he's not
going to show it
Albany and and of course just like me
here's worse they're all just crazy
because to him and he's just staring at
her
like like every Keenan Thompson
character on SNL it just goes to him and
he's like
a double shift and so um he's in and
we've been we've been tracking this and
you know we've been talking about just
like what it's been like across the
country and it's different reasons that
why it's so all right can I ask a
question sure
this job is basically reading a
teleprompter about local events like the
strawberry festival and [ __ ] right and
the state fair is coming to town right
it's it's a half hour commercial while
people wait for I think Fallon to come
on so
we couldn't just get the meteorologist
over at the desk they're waiting for
Seth Meyers to come on my Note
areas if I'm the producer I'm calling it
audible right yeah of course how how was
just not anyone there with a suit that
fits but merch brought it up the
weatherman could do this the weatherman
could easily do the sports guy could do
this being a meteorologist on the new
show is harder than being the anchor of
course because you have to interact with
the green screen and [ __ ] you can't even
see and and draw dicks and stuff with
the low pressure systems are coming in
when you're an anchor you just sit there
ain't talking to a prompter and then you
go for more let's go to Royce Lopez who
we may drive out in the Heat and a
[ __ ] fans and do the work going out
there like it's just that's the whole
point of news anyone could they could
have said yo you [ __ ] take the
earpiece out you're at the back you're
the big boy
and uh you uh you're gonna do weather
tonight weather for the night and then
she'll be like why would you like just
do it and she'll be drunk and she won't
want to like make a scene so she's like
okay that's fine
having really nice weather here so let's
get over to uh Craig gold yep Craig all
right good evening Heather and yeah the
weather has been
yep yep yep yep all right we need to
hear that Yap again that that might be
up with the jump and Jeff farmer yep yep
yep
all right good evening Heather and yeah
the weather has oh no no I didn't
anything yeah okay you want to know why
he said yep like that the producers were
talking into his ear
and the other you know and that he was
probably talking over them like yep yep
yep here so let's get over to uh Craig
gold Craig all right good evening yep
yep bro she is [ __ ] stretch the
weather out a little bit okay
um
yeah the weather has been
bands here across the North
and we're lost
then that is the
we couldn't put this guy at the desk
this guy could have easily there it's it
literally an easier job to be the main
anchor for more let's go to Chinese lady
who went to a bad neighborhood that's a
good point that's it and then you could
throw to like then you just cut the
weather out you go Hey listen let all
the Affiliates know we're gonna be uh
[ __ ] five minutes short of time we're
not gonna be able to do weather tonight
that's all or you just do the five-day
forecast on the screen and boom you move
on just cut this [ __ ] out they I think
they didn't like this chick
I really think you're right everyone
didn't like this woman and they were
just like you know what
go ahead she's probably one of those
that's always like I know what I'm
[ __ ] doing so she probably was like
whatever I'm fine they were like okay
you know what go ahead I want the
meteorologist to be the main guy anyway
so you go ahead
77 there's a live looking producers
going back and forth yeah I'm glad her
dad's dead yeah sorry see seriously yeah
you don't get it now over downtown
Saratoga Springs teeming with activity
here along Broadway 77 degrees big night
tonight listen we're gonna keep Hey
listen we're gonna keep putting things
on the green screen and I'll be
describing them to you right you're
right and we're going to stretch this
out we're going to show that the Fest
the local Festival Dave Matthews is in
town
oh my god oh and we're gonna have
tomorrow we're gonna have a a former aw
Champion uh hangman Adam page
uh you want it I'm on it so you'll see
here right now as uh you know we have
the Dave Matthews show the local uh you
know [ __ ] Amphitheater
[Music]
and uh tomorrow don't forget hangman
yeah that she's going how long is the
weather eventually she just falls asleep
spring specifically SPAC as of course
and now you're super here behind me this
is Hunter Biden's penis you'll see his
penis and a firearm and crack Matthew's
Band so if you are headed out there
oh no you only merch hadn't seen this
merch hadn't seen this he didn't know it
was Dave Matthews Band before and
neither did I because we skipped around
that was a joke
I was kidding I swear on my life verse
had no idea that I had gotten this I
thought I was like having a weird
Déjà Vu a dream moment let's see let's
see bring specifically SPAC as of course
night number two for Dave Matthews Band
so if you are headed out there you're
probably leaving yeah we're done we have
to finish we have to finish we're done
I'm not doing this anymore
I honestly feel like I'm dreaming right
now
which is oddly enough is I believe Dave
Matthews album
you know Royce I feel like I'm under the
table and dreaming
folks patreon.com yeah slash we're not
sorry that's cool sign up for five bucks
a month yeah
by the way by the way I'll say this hey
if if you're looking if you're looking
for a job drunk lady we need of course a
News correspondent on our show we can't
pay well but we'll have you yeah we'll
have you out like our woman on the
street and we encourage drinking just so
you know I encourage drinking and drug
use but I would I would please ask you
to take an Uber yes please Uber we don't
want to be responsible for that do you
just pay her like bum fights and [ __ ]
fits of shitty Aristocrat Vodka ever do
the news